des intérimaires remerciés et des
salariés contraints de poser des jours
parce que le travail manque dans les
ateliers
pour la cgt c'est sur cette situation
est le signe que l'isi automobile ne va
pas très bien
nos craintes c'est ce qu'on va regarder
les pièces produites en franche comté
est-ce qu'on va les garder chez nous où
est-ce qu'elles vont partir chez le ch
et dole usine qu'on connaît en train de
convient d'acheter en amérique si ces
pièces partent là bas c'est quasiment
sûr c'est de la perte de deux salariés
quoi l'isie fabrique des pièces pour
l'automobile l'aéronautique et le
secteur médical en franche comté le
groupe compte environ 900 salariés et il
n'y a pas que la cgt adel qui a des
craintes
les représentants des autres sites aussi
mais pour une toute autre raison
au niveau de l'aéronaute et cela des
cieux des nouvelles technologies le
développement de l' industrie 4 pajero
et les études du futur
et là aussi on a des inquiétudes parce
que l'on pourra pas préserver les mêmes
volume d'emploi quand on aura les les
robots qui remplaceront les hommes
nous avons tenté de joindre la direction
par téléphone mais elle n'a pas souhaité
prendre notre appel